نشاط المناخيين والنباتيين التخريبي كقطع
الطرقات او اقتحام مطاعم تقدم اللحوم وصلت
الى اروقه صنع القرار التي وجدت في
افعالهم سببا لاتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه قالت
انها تحمي الاكثريه من افعال الاقليه التي
باتت تعرقل حياه الناس وتكلف الملايين من
اموال دافعين ضرائب
جلسوا بعد ظهر هذا اليوم مع جميع رؤساء
الشرطه لاوضح لهم ان لديهم دعمي الكامل في
التصرف بحسم لقمع الاحتجاجات غير
القانونيه من غير المقبول ان تتم عرقله
حياه الافراد على ايدي اقليه انانيه وجهه
نظري هي ان اولئك الذين يخالفون القانون
يجب ان يشعروا بالقوه الكامله ضدهم
الشرطه البريطانيه في صدد الحصول على
سلطات جديده لقمع الاحتجاجات التي تعتبرها
الحكومه غير قانونيه وهو ما يثير جدلا في
بلد يولي اهميه كبيره لحريه الاحتجاج
صوتت ضد التشريع الذي يمنع المتظاهرين
المتطرفين من تعطيل حياه الناس العاملين
لانه ليس الى جانب العمال سيدي الرئيس
البرلمان هذا ما يريده المحافظون
سيدي رئيس البرلمان انا ضد كل من يتسببون
في الفوضى او الاضرار بخدماتنا العامه او
باقتصادنا